The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, the first thing
that we did is look at a
simple polymer model not too
different from polymer models
that we've seen before.
That is, models for molecular
configurations.
The difference in the case that
we treated last time,
though, was that instead of
having just a handful of
possible configurations with
their just, designated
energies, we had essentially an
infinite sequence of levels.
All of evenly spaced energy.
And we went through that and
saw what the thermodynamics
worked out to be.
And also with the high and low
temperature limits of the
thermodynamics turned
out to be.
And the interesting consequence
of that is that
that particular choice of
configurations and energies
associated with them maps
exactly onto the vibrational
levels of an ordinary
molecule.
So, of course, when we do the
statistical mechanics in the
end, everything depends on
the partition function.
Right?
So we're always writing some
molecular partition function.
And we've got a sum over our
energies for all the states.
And so the only input
information we need to know
is, what are the levels and
what are their energies.
So, although we started
yesterday with a model of
polymer confirmations, once we
decided what the energies
were, which was this sequence
of energies starting at zero
and going with E, and 2E, and
3E, I think we labeled them
E0, and so on, that's all that
mattered as far as the
statistical mechanics
was concerned.
And so, since we started, We
formulated this by imagining
different confirmations for a
polymer, but in fact these are
the vibrational energies
of any molecule too.
Of any vibrational mode.
So the results are very
generally applicable.
And so we saw what the
thermodynamics
worked out to be.
And what the limiting
cases were.
And a couple of them, that I'll
just review, are, one
that's very important in lots
of settings, is that the low
temperature limit when you're
down it basically zero degrees
Kelvin, that's where you've
got kT way down here.
So there's not nearly enough
thermal energy for anything to
get out of even the
lowest level.
And so in that case,
everything is
in the ground state.
And then the heat capacity,
which is this often a very
simple thing to measure, you
change the temperature.
And you see that there's
no change in the total
vibrational energy.
In other words, the limiting
low temperature
heat capacity is zero.
So we saw that for Cv
for vibrations.
And the limit that T goes
to zero was zero.
And that's because we were in
this limit, where everything
is in the ground state.
Which is to say that u
vibrational energy in that
limit is zero.
Unlike the case we treated
earlier, where we had a
limited number of levels.
Because we treated a simple
four-unit polymer with only
four possible confirmations,
in this case we have
essentially an infinite
number.
So even in the high temperature
limit, we don't
have them, there's not a
maximum total energy.
If the temperature keeps
going up, you'll get
more and more energy.
Because you can keep populating
higher and higher levels.
But the way that happens
stops changing.
Because the levels are
all evenly spaced.
So if the temperature, instead
of being down here, is
somewhere up here, now for
sure if we change the
temperature, the energy will
continue to change.
But what we've found is that in
the high temperature limit,
we had the equipartition
of energy result.
And that is, u vibrational in
the high temperature limit,
was just, for N molecules,
it was NkT.
1/2 kT for each kinetic energy
degree of freedom.
1/2 kT for each potential energy
And since vibrations have each
of those, potential and
kinetic energy, it's kT for each
molecule, for each degree
of freedom.
That's an incredibly simple,
useful thing.
That means, if I've got a
molecule in the gas phase and
it's in the high temperature
limit for translation, I know
each translational degree of
freedom will contribute for
each molecule 1/2 kT.
Or 3/2 kT, in all three
dimensions.
So I know the translational
energy of a mole of molecules
in the gas phase at room
temperature without doing
anything all.
It's 3/2 NkT.
Rotations, if it's a diatomic
molecule, will be two
different degrees of freedom.
For rotation.
In two orthogonal planes.
And I'll have 1/2 kT for each.
1/2 NkT for N molecules.
For vibrations, if I'm in a high
temperature limit, then
it'll be kT for each
vibrational mode.
For molecules, the vibrational
frequencies are usually high,
so that you're not in the
high temperature limit.
But for materials where you
have vibrations, acoustic
vibrations, those are
low frequency.
You can be in the high
temperature limit.
And easily are.
So the result for energy for
vibrational energy in the high
temperature limit, was NkT.
And so that means that the heat
capacity in that same
limit at high temperature was
just Nk, derivative with
respect to temperature.
Very simple thing to
measure, again.
So that's what we saw last time
in the case of both the
conformational model that we
treated and the vibrational
energies of molecules onto which
that same model maps.
Now what I want to do, is
look a little further.
And let me actually write the
partition functions too.
Also an important result was
that the partition function
itself, q vibrational, in the
high temperature limit, was
just kT over E0.
Also very simple result.
E0 is h nu 0 for vibrational
mode with frequency nu 0.
And of course, given the
partition function you can
calculate everything.
So in the high temperature
limit we can
easily calculate things.
In the low temperature limit,
it's just one, right?
There's only one allowed
possible state in the low
temperature limit.
Everything is in the ground
state when it's cold enough.
So the sum of our states just
gives us exactly one term
that's of any reasonable
value.
That is, the term with this
being the lowest energy.
Everything else, the energy
is much bigger than kT.
This is a vanishingly
small number then.
So just write q, vibrational, in
the low temperature limit,
is just one.
OK, that was the case
for vibration.
And remember, these low
temperature limiting cases,
that's a common case for nearly
any degree of freedom.
As long as it's quantized.
At some point, you'll
get this situation.
Where the temperature is low
compared to even the lowest
excited level.
Of course, what'll happen in
the high temperature limit
might vary, depending
on the structure
of the energy levels.
In the case of vibrations, it's
like this, it'll turn out
rotations do the same thing.
But it's not always
as simple as this.
OK, now what I want to do is
just go through the next step
of what we can treat, given
the statistical
mechanics that we know.
Which is chemical equilibrium.
Why can't we just calculate
equilibrium constants based on
what we've seen so far.
If we can calculate the
partition functions for
molecules, and they undergo
reactions and they're in
equilibrium, we should
be able to calculate
the equilibrium constants.
From first principles, just
based on the statistical math
we've seen so far.
So let's try to do that.
So it just means that, again,
just as always, if we know all
the energy levels and what all
the possible states are,
there's no reason we shouldn't
be able to set our sights on a
calculation of that sort.
So let's just sketch out what
the levels are going to look
like for simple chemical
events.
So I just want to draw an energy
diagram, here's energy.
And, like we often do with
chemical equilibria, I'm going
to set the zero of energy at the
separated atoms, and I'm
imagining I've got reactants
and products.
So let's make this
our products.
Then over here we'll have our
reactants and make the
energies different.
Alright.
So there's some amount of
binding energy, right?
There's a bond dissociation
energy going from the lowest
available level in each molecule
to the dissociation
limit where we pulled
the atoms apart.
So now I'm going to draw
vibrational energy levels
inside the molecule.
Let's imagine, it wouldn't need
to be this, but let's
imagine it's just diatomic
molecules.
So there's one vibrational
mode in each.
Just the stretching mode.
And we've already seen the
levels are evenly spaced.
So there's going to be a bunch
of evenly spaced levels.
Actually, it stopped being quite
evenly spaced once this
stops being a simple harmonic
oscillator, but for all the
low lying levels it's pretty
close to that.
So those are the available
levels.
And there's a dissociation
energy.
So minus E, and I'll call this
for the products, Ep.
And it's just minus D0
for the products.
Right, in language, terminology
that we've seen before.
And it's the same thing
for the reactants.
And really, if this were more
than a diatomic molecule,
maybe there would be a bunch
of vibrational modes.
But it wouldn't matter.
This would just represent all
the vibrational energies.
There's some lowest
state available.
So now we've got the
dissociation
energy for the reactants.
So those are the energies
it takes to
separate the molecule.
But those aren't the only states
available to molecules.
Of course, they could have
extra vibrational energy.
They're not always in
their ground states.
And we're going to calculate
partition functions.
In general we would sum over
all the available states.
And then just calculate
the probability of
being in the state.
One way to look at this, since
if there's chemical
equilibrium between the
species, it means the
molecules can interconvert.
What that really means is that
any of the molecule has access
to any of these states.
Of course, we like to group all
these states over here.
Because they correspond to a
particular chemical structure.
And we like to group these
states over here, because they
correspond to this different
chemical structure.
From a statistical mechanics
point of view, it's just
states and levels.
And we could just calculate
the probability of any
molecule being in any
one of the states.
But it's useful to keep them
separated like this.
So let's do that.
And let's look at the
difference here, the
difference in dissociation
energy.
Delta D0.
Let's not put a double arrow.
Let's define the sign of it.
This way, going from products
to reactants.
OK, now let's just look at how
equilibrium should work.
So now, let's just take
a generic reaction.
Little a, our number, our
stoichiometric number, A plus
b, and B goes to c C, d D. And
we know that delta G0 is minus
RT log of Kp.
And that delta G0 is just the
free energy of the products
minus the free energy
of the reactants.
So it's c times G C0 plus
d G D0 minus a G A0
minus b G equals B0.
So we need to know the
free energy of
each one of the species.
And now we know how to calculate
that from first
principles, through statistical
mechanics.
So we know that G
is A plus pV.
A is minus kT log of capital
Q. And I'm going to assume
that we're in the gas phase.
And it's an ideal gas, so I'm
going to replace pV by NkT.
And what's Q?
Well, we know what Q is.
It's q, little q,
to the N power
translational over N factorial.
For atoms, this is
all it would be.
But we have molecules.
So we have individual other
degrees of freedom besides
translation.
So let me just label those
internal, q internal.
And that's also to
the N power.
And q internal, if you say,
what are those degrees of
freedom, well it's the
electronic energy. it's the
vibrational energy.
It's the rotational energy.
And we'll deal with those
shortly, but let's just
separate it this way for now.
Just we can keep track of where
the N factorial belongs.
And now we're going to use
Stirling's approximation for
the N factorial.
So our log of Q, which we need
up here, is just N log of q
trans q internal minus
log of N factorial.
And that's just equal to N log
q trans q internal, minus N
log N. Plus N. And of course,
this I'm going to put down
here momentarily.
And now our expression
for G is up there.
So it's minus kT log
of Q plus NkT.
So these factors of N
are going to cancel.
So when I take minus kT log of
Q, that's going to be minus
NkT over here.
That's going to cancel
the plus NkT here.
So all I'm going to have left
is this term and this term.
Which I can combine.
So it's just minus NkT log of
q translational q internal
over N. Now these, really, are
just the same as q, it's just
minus NkT log of little q over
N. I didn't need to separate
that into this product.
I only wanted to do it to be
clear where we were getting
this factor of N
factorial from.
So now we have an expression
for G. And if we know G for
all the species involved in a
chemical reaction, we should
be able to calculate the
chemical equilibrium.
So let's do it.
So now to do it, let's look a
little more closely at what
these internal degrees
of freedom are.
Because that's where these
important details are
going to come in.
Obviously the equilibrium is
going to depend on the
energetics.
How much different are the
bonding energies or the
dissociation energies and
the molecules involved.
And also, how much different
or the other
molecular energy levels.
The vibrations, rotations,
and so forth.
So, q internal is the product
of rotational, vibrational,
and electronic partition
functions.
Remember how we saw that if you
can write the energy as a
sum of energies, then the
partition functions are
multiplied.
Because, of course, if this is
the sum of a rotational plus
vibrational plus electronic
energy, then of course I can
just separate out
these things.
These are in the exponent.
I can write it as a product.
Same with translations.
I already have separated that.
So now let's look at how
these things behave.
Well, for the electronic case,
there's really only one
electronic state of interest
in general.
And that's the lowest state.
In cases you're extremely
familiar with, if it were the
hydrogen atom, it would be
down in the 1s orbital.
And it would take a huge amount
of energy to get up
into the 2s or 2p orbital.
At ordinary temperatures
you never have that.
All the atoms would be
in the ground state.
Now, for most molecules, it
don't take as much energy as
for the hydrogen atom.
If you have benzene, for
example, the ground electronic
state, the lowest electronic
state, is quite far below the
first excited state.
Not as much as the hydrogen atom
going from 1s to 2s to
2p, but still by much more than
ordinary thermal energies
at room temperature.
And what that means is, again,
only the ground state term is
going to matter.
Now, sometimes we would
define that is this
as the zero of energy.
But since we're doing chemical
equilibria, the zero of energy
is up here.
So that epsilon, that energy
term, is this amount.
The dissociation energy.
This is minus dissociation
energy.
So we're going to have a
positive number there.
So q electronic is just
e to the D0 over kT.
So that's easy enough.
We also know what
the vibrational
partition function is.
We saw it last time.
It's this thing we could
write as a simple form.
One over one minus e to the
minus E, I'll call it
E vibe, over kT.
It's h nu 0, where nu is the
vibrational frequency.
Again, in the case of many
molecules, the vibrational
energy is pretty high
compared to kT.
So even this often simplifies
to be just one.
In other words, all the
molecules, in many cases, are
basically all of them are in the
ground vibrational state
at room temperature.
Certainly if you look at
molecules of high frequencies,
if you look at the hydrogen
molecule, H2, the vibrational
frequency is about 4,000
wave numbers.
Remember I mentioned last time,
kT at room temperature,
T is 300 Kelvin.
Then kT corresponds to
200 wave numbers.
It's a factor of 2/3.
Much less than 4,000
wave numbers.
In other words, the vibrational
energy is much
lower than kT.
So, again, everything would
be in the lowest level.
And this just simplifies
to one.
In many cases, it's reasonably
close to one.
For high vibrational
frequencies, nu 0.
Now, we haven't talked
about rotation.
But you probably have just an
intuitive feeling that at
ordinary temperatures, if I do
this, if I wave my hand in the
air, molecules that I happen
to intersect are going to
start spinning faster.
In other words, ordinary thermal
energies do populate
some number of rotational
levels of molecules.
Molecules probably aren't
going to start getting
squished together and vibrate
harder when I do
something like this.
So molecules might generally
still be in the ground
vibrational levels, thermal
energy isn't enough to raise
them in many cases.
But rotation, for sure.
They're not all in
the lowest level.
Turns out that, in fact, the
energy separation between
rotational levels is very small
compared to kT at room
temperature.
So just like we saw for the
high temperature limit for
vibrations, it turns out that
for q rotation in the high
temperature limit, we have the
same situation where we have
kT over, now it's a
rotational energy.
And it's typically on the order
of about one to ten wave
numbers for small to medium
sized molecules.
Remember, too, last time when
we talked about in the
vibrational levels and said,
well, if you're at kT and it's
this big, it's basically telling
you roughly how many
levels do you have thermal
access to.
Because we saw the same results
for vibrations.
It's not so different
for rotation.
And it turns out that at
ordinary temperatures, you
might have access to a few
tens to a few hundreds of
rotational levels, depending on
whether they're closer to
one or ten wave numbers
or a little higher.
Again, room temperature
is 200 wave numbers.
So, that means that, remember
q is a unitless number.
You're counting the states,
weighted by the energy.
Weighted by the Boltzmann
factor.
And for rotations, it's a number
that might be on the
order of 100 or so.
Order of magnitude estimate,
that's all.
And of course we've seen the
translational partition
function is on the order of
10 to the 30th, right?
Enormous number.
In other words, in the simple
lattice model that we've use
to describe translation, just
breaking up the available
volume into little pieces.
Counting.
Well, OK, you have something on
the order of 10 to the 30th
possible locations.
And if you treat this
properly, quantum
mechanically, for the
translations, there's actually
a magnitude of the number
is similar.
Now I just want to go through
a very simple example.
Just treating a particular
generic reaction.
And look at what the equilibrium
constant is.
Working it through, given
what we've seen so far.
So I just want to simplify
it by having all the
stoichiometric coefficients
equal to one.
It's not a great complication,
if we don't do that.
But it's a little bit simpler.
So let's take a molecule that's
A-B plus C-D. And now
let's break bonds
and reform them.
So we get A-C plus B-D, right?
So we're going to do
something simple.
And since I've got all the
stoichiometric coefficients
equal to one, we've got the same
number of molecules as
reactants and products, that'll
make things a little
bit easier.
Just in the sense that if we
look at the contribution of
the translational energies at
room temperature, they're
going to be the same.
For the reactants and
the products.
Any of the molecules is going
to have a translational
partition function on the order
of 10 to the 30th, at
room temperature and
an ordinary volume.
And nothing's going to change
from reactants to products.
And for vibrations, let's
assume, as is often the case,
that the vibrational frequencies
are fairly high.
So all the partition functions
for the vibrations
are equal to one.
Like we've got written
up there.
For all four of the molecules.
So then nothing is going to
change in the vibrations.
Going from reactants
to products.
Finally, the rotations.
So, for the rotations our
partition function is
something on the order of, I
think I meant to write 100,
not ten here.
As our order of magnitude.
That's what it's going to be.
It's a number on that order.
And if we assume that the masses
of the atoms involved
are comparable, then we can
cheat a little bit and say
that's also, those numbers are
also, going to be comparable
for the reactants and
the products.
We don't have to do that.
We could put it in, and rather
easily calculate it.
But I'm going to make life
simple in this way and just
work through how to carry
through the calculation.
And I think it'll be clear how
to put in different partition
functions for those quantities
if they are different from
each other.
OK, so let's try it.
Then, our delta G0, let's
go back over here.
Here's delta G, let me just
put the relationship up.
So we've got an expression for
G. Which is, let's start from
back there.
It's minus.
And now for each one of the
substances, it's Ni
kT log qi over Ni.
I'm just going to put
this in molar terms.
So it's minus little ni RT.
Log of qi over capital Ni.
And I only want to do that
because I want to express this
in free energy.
This is for substance i.
Free energy per mole.
So it's just minus RT
log of qi over Ni.
That's G per mole.
That's Gi naught per mole.
Plus RT log pi over p0.
Where p0 is an atmosphere,
basically.
One bar.
So that means Gi0
bar is minus RT.
And I'm going to take this minus
this and combine them.
So it's log of qi over
Ni, that's this part.
And now I've got log of pi over
p, and I'm just going to
use the ideal gas law.
So I'm going to use pV is nRT.
So then I've got Ni kT
over my factor of
p0, times the volume.
So that's Gi0 for each one
of the substances.
The Ni's cancel.
And I've got minus RT log of qi
kT over p0 times V. Now, qi
is just the total molecular
partition function.
It's this product of q trans
times q rotational times q
vibrational times
q electronic.
And now I need delta G. So delta
G0, is just minus RT.
And now it's just, I'm going to
take this for each one of
the substances, for the
products, minus the reactants.
And I'm going to combine
the log terms.
This is the same, and
I'm going to have
this in every term.
So what's going to happen?
Well, all this stuff
is going to cancel.
Now, that doesn't necessarily
happen.
That happens because of
the stoichiometric
numbers being the same.
Otherwise I'd have to take them
to that the power of the
stoichiometric number.
But in this case they're just
going to simply cancel.
So I'm going to have left is
the ratio of my partition
function for molecule AC.
Partition function
for molecule BD.
Partition function for
molecule AB, and
for molecule CD.
Products, reactants.
Pretty simple, because
I know how to
calculate all this stuff.
And again I'd suggested some
simplifying assumptions for
what those partition
functions are.
But it wouldn't be hard to
calculate each one of them if
I just had all the relevant
energy levels.
To make this simple, we're
going to assume that the
rotational energies are the same
for all the molecules.
It wouldn't need to be, it
wouldn't be hard, to plug in
different values.
We're going to assume we're in
the low temperature limit for
vibrations.
So q vibrational for
each one of these
things is equal to one.
The translational contributions,
are equal for
all of them.
So the only thing that's
different is the electronic
contribution.
And that's different.
Because, of course, you have
different electronic energies.
The binding energies for the
products and the reactants
aren't in general going
to be equal.
And in most cases, it is the
energetics that dominate the
equilibrium constants.
Of course, that is, it's the
electronic energies that
usually dominate.
Of course, the other
things do matter.
But it's not unusual for the
electronic energies to dominate.
So here's delta G0.
Of course, this is minus
RT log of Kp.
So there's our expression for
our equilibrium constants.
So it's just this product.
So let's just put in the
partition functions for the
electronic part.
It's e to the D0 over
kT for molecule AC.
Times e to the D0 for
molecule BD over kT.
Divided by e to the D0 for AB
over kT, times e to the D0 for
molecule CD over kT.
So the whole thing is just e to
the D0 AC, plus D0 BD minus
D0 AB minus D0 CD over kT.
Or in other words, it's e
to the delta D0 over kT.
That's the whole story.
So it's a super-simple
calculation to execute.
And for lots of molecules,
we know the
dissociation energies.
These are measured,
determined, either
thermochemically or
spectroscopically for a great
many molecules.
So in fact, we have the
information we need to do that
calculation.
And if we want to worry about
the vibrational and rotational
levels, typically we have
that information, too,
spectroscopically.
So we know what the relevant
energy levels are to do the
whole calculation.
So what it means is, we can
calculate equilibrium
constants for ordinary chemical
reactions just from
first principles.
Knowing the energy levels
of the available
states of the molecules.
Any questions?
In your notes I've included
another example.
It's a little bit of
an extra example.
You can go through
it if you'd like.
It turns out to have a kind of
attractive closed form solution.
Which is the case of a chemical
reaction like an
isomerization inside a
crystalline solid.
So you can imagine you've got
a crystal of some molecule,
many crystals, thermally over
time, they might decompose.
They might have reaction
processes that can take place.
So I've imagined you've
got uni-molecular
reactions that can occur.
And in that case you
start with a pure
crystal of one species.
And you end up with a mixture of
some number of the original
species, and some number
of new species.
And there's an equilibrium
constant that'll say where
that should be.
So again, it'll depend
on the energies.
On the dissociation energies
of the different species.
And there's also a kind of
mixing term, because
effectively now you've got the
different species located at
different places
in the crystal.
Those are distinguishable
states, in the solid.
And you need to count those.
But the one other example I
want to work through is a
little bit different from
chemical equilibria.
It's phase equilibria.
Why shouldn't we be able to
calculate phase diagrams?
So in the earlier part of the
course, you went through and
saw the macroscopic
thermodynamic treatment.
The equilibrium constants
and chemical equilibria.
So of course you saw the whole
delta G0 as minus RT log Kp
and so forth.
And you've seen now we can
actually calculate all that
from first principles.
What about phase equilibria?
What you saw before, we just
drew phase diagrams.
And they had boiling points
or lines of boiling.
Or in other words, liquid-solid
and liquid-gas
and solid-gas equilibria.
And what we did is, given where
those lines fell, you
can calculate things.
But where do the lines fall?
What's the boiling point or the
sublimation temperature of
some material at a particular
pressure?
Well, we didn't offer
any prescription
for calculating that.
You had to take that from
measurement and then given
that, you could use the
Clausius-Clapeyron equation
and so forth and look at the
way things behaved if you
moved along a line in
a phase diagram.
But there was no prescription
offered to calculate where
exactly would that line be
on the phase diagram.
But again, if you know all the
energies of the possible
states, in the solid, in
the liquid and the gas,
statistical mechanics shows us
that we can calculate the
equilibrium between those.
Which is to say we know
we can calculate
where those lines belong.
So I want to just go through
maybe one of a couple of
relatively simple cases.
I want to go through the case of
a solid-solid equilibrium.
Let's imagine we have two
solid phases and an
equilibrium between them.
And this problem was
on the problem set.
How many of you did it?
Everybody did it.
Did you all get to
the end of it?
Who got to the end of it?
Some of you got to
the end of it.
If you did, congratulations,
it's not so trivial to work on
for the first time.
So I'll just briefly go
through that problem.
And show how it works.
So, it's similar, of
course, to the case
that we're doing now.
To the case we just did,
of chemical equilibria.
The difference, though, is
that it's cooperative.
The solid, at least in the way I
formulated that problem, you
either have the crystal in phase
one or phase alpha, or
in phase beta.
And there's nothing
in between.
There are lots of systems
like that.
Not just crystals,
you could go from
different forms of DNA.
Act like that.
Where you have super coiled
DNA and regular DNA.
And you actually can have
some of the DNA in each.
But it's actually very
cooperative.
So there's a huge tendency to
either be all in one, or be
all in the other.
Or at least very very, large
pieces of it like that.
Lots of other systems
act like that.
In other words, unlike the
case where we're thinking
about chemical equilibrium among
molecules in the gas
phase, these two molecules
over here crash into each
other and they react.
Nothing else cares.
The other whole mole of
molecules does whatever they
were doing.
And a little later some other
pair of molecules happen to
crash into each other and maybe
react or maybe don't.
In other words, there's no
cooperativity at all.
What happens to some pair of
reactants and products,
everything else is completely
independent of it.
That's not the case when you
have, in many cases, a phase
transition.
You can see it by eye, often.
If you do something like
super cool water.
This is a kind of
fun experiment.
If you take dry ice,
and you've got a
little bit of water.
Right or a little
pot of water.
And you put some dry
ice into it.
So you can actually get the
water to be below the freezing
temperature and it
won't freeze yet.
Then you drop a crystal
in there and
boom, it all freezes.
Very cooperatively.
Lots of phase transitions
behave like that.
So let's just see
how it works.
In this case, it's really
similar to what we just did.
We can treat it, here's
phase alpha.
Here's phase beta.
And the crystal, the
interactions between molecules
or the atoms in the crystal are
different in the two phases.
So effectively, the binding
energy is different.
In other words, if you say, now
let's think of the energy
it would take to evaporate all
the atoms or molecules and let
them loose in the gas phase.
That's the analog of
dissociation for the molecule.
You're pulling everything apart
from the crystal and
separating them all.
So that's what we'll call
these energies.
This'll be minus E alpha.
And this will be minus E beta.
And then there are vibrational
energies.
So the lattice has a bunch
of vibrational energies.
We can assume they're
evenly spaced.
And they're going
to be different.
They're not the same in the two
different crystalline forms.
That's typically the case.
You have a phase transition from
one crystal to another.
The lattice vibrational
frequencies aren't
the same any more.
Speed of sound is different.
Things are different.
And that's all.
That's the only thing
that's different.
So these are binding
energies per atom.
So now, let's just try to
calculate Q. And what we are
supposed to get out of this
is, what's the phase
transition temperature?
That's the thing that we didn't
have any prescription
for calculating before.
We just said, here it is.
Here's the boiling point.
Here's the melting point,
or whatever the
phase transition was.
Or if we drew a phase diagram,
here's the line.
But now we're going to try to
calculate where that is.
Or what those temperatures
are.
So, Q for either phase it's
just e to the E over kT.
Just like we saw before for the
dissociation energies of molecules.
To the Nth power.
No N factorial any more.
There's no translation.
Times the vibrational part.
This is the electronic
partition function.
And then there's the
vibrational part.
And that's one over one minus
e to the minus h nu, what's
called E over kT, for the
lattice I'm assuming it's just
one frequency.
So this energy is h nu E. And of
course, it's different for
the alpha and beta phases.
And I'm going to assume we're in
the high temperature limit.
Which is often the case for
lattice vibrations.
So it's e to the, little
E over kT.
For our electronic part,
to the Nth power.
And we've seen what the high
temperature limit is.
It's kT over h nu E.
And that's also,
that to the 3N power.
I should have written
this here.
In other words if you say, how
many vibrations are there in
the lattice, well if there are
N atoms, each atom in the gas
phase would have three
degrees of freedom.
Translational degrees
of freedom.
In the crystal, it can't
freely translate.
But those degrees of freedom
are still there.
The atoms can all move.
So now, those are the
lattice vibrations.
When the atoms try to
move, they vibrate
against each other.
So how many different
modes are there?
They may be degenerate.
They may all have
the same energy.
But those modes are
all still there.
Actually, they're the acoustic
modes of the crystal.
And there are 3N of them.
One for each translational
degree or freedom
that each atom had.
OK, so that's it.
A, minus kT log of Q,
so it's just minus
NE, and the kT cancels.
Minus 3NkT log of kT over
h nu E. Second part.
And then we can calculate
the chemical potential.
It's just the dA/dN,
d constant T and V.
So this goes away.
It's just minus little E. This
goes away, it's minus 3kT log
of kT over h nu E. Well,
basically we just finished.
At the phase transition
temperature for the two
phases, those things
have to be equal.
And that's all there is to it.
So, at, we'll call it Tc, the
phase transition temperature,
I guess I called it T1 here, mu
alpha is equal to mu beta.
So this stuff for alpha is
equal to this for beta.
That's it.
So what does it say?
It says E beta minus E alpha,
these terms, equals 3kT1 log
of nu E beta over nu E alpha.
Solve for T1.
That's it.
It's E beta minus E alpha
over 3k log nu E
beta over nu E alpha.
There is our phase transition
temperature.
That's the whole story.
So if we know the electronic
energy that binds the crystal
together, usually something that
can be measured easily,
so it's known for
many materials.
And if we know the lattice
vibrational frequency.
Also something that's
pretty routinely
measured, we're done.
So again, from a very simple
first principles approach, we
can calculate that phase
transition temperature.
We could do it for a solid-gas
equilibria too, if we said OK,
let's think of sublimation
of the solid.
And now we know how to calculate
the chemical
potential in the gas phase.
We can have those be equal.
That's actually worked through
in your notes.
Again, it's an extra problem.
If you would like to take
a look at it, it's a
straightforward calculation.
The point is, we can calculate
those phase equilibria.
Liquids, I will say,
are harder.
Just because it's harder to
define and know all the
energies available.
Doable, approximately.
But the point is, we can
actually now locate all those
lines that we sort of
arbitrarily drew
on the phase diagrams.
And make sense of what the
temperatures and what the
pressures are, for that matter,
where they occur.
Any questions?